this program is brought to you by Emory
University hello everybody we're so glad
to see you here today and we hope you've
had a good morning I know you've been
busy since 8 o'clock that's very early
to start your retreats
I'm Susan Ashmore I'm an associate
professor of history at Oxford College
and I serve as a faculty counselor to
the Audit Committee for the board of
trustees and I teach modern American
history and my scholarship focuses on
the 20th century south so I wanted to
ask you to please put your cell phones
on silent if you haven't done that
already
that'll be make our time together really
great so we have two of Emory's best
historians with us to discuss why
history matters and there are full
biographies I think in your little
booklet so I will only make the briefest
of introductions in order to use our
time wisely dr. patrick allit will speak
first and he is the kahun family
professor of American history he grew up
in England and has been teaching
American history at Emory since 1988 in
2009 Yale University Press published his
most recent book the Conservatives ideas
and personalities throughout American
history in a June interview about his
new book he said I argue that
conservatism is contextual and reactive
conservatives believe that civilization
is complex precious and delicate always
vulnerable to threats from external
enemies and from impetuous reformers
within as the threats have changed over
the decades so has the nature of
conservatism dr. Deborah Lipstadt is the
Douro professor of modern Jewish history
and Holocaust Studies in 1998 she
created the Institute for Jewish Studies
at Emory and directed this Institute
until 2008 her new book the Eichmann
trial she brought a copy today so we can
read that was published this year
commemorate in the commemoration of the
50th anniversary of the Eichmann trial
you may have seen Franklin fors review
in the
April 10th New York Times Book Review it
was an amazing review
he said Lipstadt has done a great
service by untethering the trial from
Hannah Arendt's polarizing presence
recovering the event as a gripping legal
drama as well as a hinge moment in
Israel's history and in the world's
delayed awakening to the magnitude of
the Holocaust so you can tell from the
subjects of their most recent books that
indeed history matters first we'll hear
from dr. allit then dr. lips taught and
then we will have some conversation
thanks very much indeed it's a great
pleasure to be here
as you can tell from my voice I'm
English and I teach American history to
American kids here at Emory Kathina so
there's always a strange moment at the
beginning of every semester when the
students listen to me for a minute or
two and they say you're the US history
teacher but they're so charming and so
gracious that after the first few days I
think the the strangeness and novelty
wears off and we get right down to
business
now when have you noticed that most
people get more interested in history as
they get older so it's a kids to most
children history is a bit of an ordeal
it's a bit of a trial well I guess the
textbooks are so heavy and dull and
lifeless and of course if the history
teacher is bad learning history is just
appalling as I know eating cold brussel
sprouts
it could hardly have less engagement
with their own lives but then isn't it
true that actually get to older
especially once you've passed your 50th
birthday you start realizing that you're
actually part of history this reason
something just happened once and for all
and then finished it's actually going on
now and that you'd be the participants
in it and then what your kids read about
is the Carter Administration now you say
oh I remember this in fact I knew
President Carter you can talk to them
and say now this is a real person facing
real issues and problems and then of
course when you talk to your kids or
grandchildren they they're facing it or
they can be fascinated to learn about
the world in which you you grow up a
world of incredible hardships you know
without personal computers a world of
typewriters and fountain pens and record
players and things like this
and the stuff and you say well it was
perfectly ordinary in our day we didn't
regard ourselves as living lives of
horrifying privation
if just what the world was like and the
kids get high incredible you know and I
was thinking I remember this when I was
a granular student at Berkeley back in
the early 80s I had a girlfriend who was
just working as a temp at a law firm and
she came home one day she said they've
got this incredible thing at work it's
like a typewriter attached to a TV and
when you when you put in the words they
come up on the TV and if you miss a word
what a great thing
obviously by now you know a few years
we'd all got one had anyway so one of
the uses of history is just to kind of
think about your own life and the way in
which the context the setting of your
own life has been changing but obviously
there's a lot more to it than that
history is really the only thing we've
got to understand the world that we've
come from and to think about the kind of
world that we might be moving into
inevitably we're interested in trying to
think about the future and history gives
us a fund of lessons to apply in
thinking about what's going to happen
next but now there are temptations with
history and I think there are particular
temptations from American history if
you're American you're a citizen of a
country that's been very lucky it's
actually possible to think of American
history it's a series of moral jumps and
in fact this is a way in which doesn't
test again thought this way in grade
school and sometimes even in high school
this idea that back in the 18th century
America had a terrible problem and the
problem was the British but my luckily
they overcame it in the revolutions have
moved up onto a higher plane and then in
the 19th early 19th century they had a
terrible problem which was the problem
of slavery but then they overcame it in
the Civil War moved up to another level
if you remember learning it like this
they're somehow easy to get into the
frame of mind of thinking that the
history is the struggle of right against
wrong in which right wins now America's
are the very very few places you can
actually study history that way you
certainly couldn't do that if you lived
in Poland or Ireland you think about
polish history it's all tragedy yeah you
can't possibly make a sign that each
stage of polish history is somehow
higher and better than the other
and since you realize that if it gets
you thinking so perhaps history isn't
really the struggle of brighter gates
wrong in which right comes out ahead
it might not really be like that now I
think I'm constantly saying to students
here at Emory is this history is not a
struggle of right against wrong it's the
struggle of right against right they
don't like that because it takes away
this very very emotionally gratifying
feeling I mean if you ever have this
experience you what you're moving at the
end you feel there's enormous cathartic
sense of rightness and happiness and
contentment yeah yeah when you hear a
historical lesson which gives you that
feeling it's almost certainly bad
history yeah history's not really like
that history is much much more
complicated it won't give you gratifying
little lessons or at least it will only
do so if you cut it up in very very
particular ways and leave out all sorts
of difficult and awkward information so
what I'm teaching history I say just use
well it's the conflict of variety games
right I mean for example I sometimes say
to students read to a student when was
the last time in which the Confederacy
could realistically expect to win the
Civil War and sometimes the students say
oh but they were the losers almost as
though they'd marched into battle
thinking we're the losers a nice
difficult it's difficult to get back
into the frame of mind of people who
didn't know they were the losers of
course the better students very quickly
understand the point so I think that was
it just before Pickett's Charge and
Gettysburg
they speculate like that and then I say
now what were the arguments the
Confederates use to convince themselves
that they were right you know what about
the defenders of slavery did the defense
of slavery say we're wrong and we know
it now surely they didn't say that they
said we're right and here's why we're
right
they had arguments to make and to
understand the history of slavery or the
history of anything you've got to get
the students to think like the sly bones
you've got to get them at least
provisionally into the mind of the
person who's doing something which they
assuredly now disapprove of I mean
you've got to be very quick on your feet
to be a good historian first you've got
to see the world ask the slave owner saw
it then you've got to see the world as
the slave saw it then you've got to see
the world as the abolitionists saw it
and then you've got to see the world as
the the northern anti abolitionists eyes
to understand all these different groups
so we're all conflicting in conflict
with each other
all thinking that they were right
because of course people come into
conflict because they think they're
right and sometimes because they're even
willing to die for their belief in their
rightness yeah that's why it's so
difficult and why it's so complicated
and of course it's a great discipline
and I sometimes say this to students as
well it's a discipline being a student
you've got to have the discipline to sit
still and listen you've also got that
you've got to have the discipline to
think uncomfortable thoughts if you only
think comfortable thoughts you're never
really going to understand history at
all it's much more difficult than that
now the next thing is this question
about the lessons of history and
politicians love talking about the
lessons of history but let me counsel
you if we've got another presidential
season coming up as soon as a politician
from either party says here's the lesson
of history what what will happen next is
that you won't be told the truth or at
least you won't be tired and similarly
when a politician says the American
people instantly that's about to turn up
isn't it because the American people
don't want anything there's all sorts of
groups of people they want different
things where was I all right lessons in
history it is true that we can derive
lessons from history but it's hardly
ever the case that you can look at the
historical incidents and say ah here's
what happened and therefore here's the
lesson hardly ever I give you an example
after the terrible tragedy of the First
World War when people look back at what
had happened in 1914 to start the
fighting what they said was we were too
quick to jump into conflict and the
reason we were so quick was because we
believed that now that warfare was so
mechanized now that there were railroads
and machine operated weapons
anyone who didn't mobilize quickly was
going to be as a terrible disadvantage
yeah well we're all on a hair-trigger
alert from fear that if it didn't
mobilize quickly we'd lose almost
straightaway and that's why of course in
the 1930s
the possibility of a new war began to
approach the responsible politicians in
Europe said let's not make that mistake
again let's be careful
let's appease Hitler appeasement was the
adult that grown-up the sensible thing
to do which applied the lessons of the
First World War but of course it went
tragically wrong didn't it because it
isn't as though Hitler was a beast on
the contrary he interpreted this as a
sign of weakness which he was able to
exploit so then after the Second World
War
fight the enemy early when he's far away
and weak because if you don't you gonna
have to fight him later when he's
stronger and closer that's why the
Americans went to war in Vietnam Vietnam
foes no kind of problem to America
directly and in mid-1960s but the lesson
of what had happened in the white 30s
was the lesson being applied so there
are certain lessons Wallace goes more
quickly and the only one is don't and of
course because history never really
repeats itself
anyone who's choosing one lesson knows
that they're going to choose a lesson
which might prove to be completely wrong
and the conditions have changed anyway
very very difficult indeed and of course
people with the very best motives and
intentions can make the wrong decision
and they do so constantly we can all
think of examples of that and let me
give you one more example which is
actually a little segue into into dr.
Lipstadt talk during the First World War
nineteen I'm especially after 1917 when
the Americans went into the war directly
themselves there were lots of stories
circulating in America about the
terrible atrocities that the Germans had
done there's a great burst of anti
German fever in America that they raped
the nuns in Belgium and they crucified
prisoners of war that they committed
horrible acts of atrocity
now when and and this wasn't only in the
papers it was preached by ministers you
know saying if Jesus may have preached
peace in his at the time but that's only
cos didn't face anyone as horrible as
the Germans are now after the war these
stories almost all proved to be untrue
and a lot of Americans have used these
stories felt deeply ashamed of having
believed them and of having spread them
around and said to themselves
conscientiously we're not going to
believe stories like that again now the
result is that in the 19th
when they started hearing about Hitler's
persecution of the Jews they said we've
heard stories like that before we got
taken in by these crazy atrocity stories
we're not going to do that again and so
they were skeptical I mean one of the
terrible terrible difficulties for
Jewish organizations in America was to
get people to believe it was really
happening so again you see the Americans
were wrong twice they were wrong the
first time for being too credulous and
they were wrong the second time for
being too skeptical it's very very
difficult II need to know what the law
what the lessons of history are and
finally it's very difficult to know
about the future have you ever had this
experience
you think I'm finally going to clear out
the basement what did after years now
I'm going to clean out the basement done
that and you go down there any fun
things you find it's a pile of old life
magazines from 1950 yeah and so rather
than actually clean out the base we
start with these fascinating old
magazines and they're all they smell a
bit harder and then you come to one from
1951 and it says the world in the year
2000 what it's going to be like and it's
good Larry it's a funny isn't it because
it's so wrong in other words the
nineteen fifty idea and what the year
2000 was going to be like was it tells
you right about that year that the
predictions were made but nothing at all
about the year which was being predicted
that's all we're all going to have our
own personal health nuclear-powered
hovercraft no you look you know hey
where's mine
but it doesn't say anything it's all
about computers or bottled water or all
the things that we actually lived with
in 2000 so predictions of the future are
usually hopeless occasionally somebody
stumbles upon something which does turn
out to be prophetic but it's very very
hard indeed to say which of the
thousands of predictions that are always
being made it's going to turn out to be
a reasonable one and believe it is that
and turn over to Deborah
I've last at dr. Alex Patrick's he's
British he calls me doctor little said
I'm American I call him Patrick I
laughed at his final comment about
knowing the future just before I came
here I received an email from I had
received an email previously from a
teacher in Australia who asked fun of
her seniors one of her top form students
could ride me with some questions so she
had questions about my teaching about
the Holocaust other things and then she
said so what does your knowledge of the
Holocaust tell you about the future and
I wrote back I said I'm just figuring
out the past I can't even handle for
doing other things and I think that's
entirely true that it's when anybody
uses we I wouldn't say that we want to
take history to say you can't learn
anything about the future but when
anybody takes history it says this
teaches us a B C and D exactly run for
the exits
if you glean from things and then you
put it together and try to to discern
what it might teach you then I think
you're in good shape a couple of points
about first of all my teaching and then
to react to some of the points that
Patrick made in my class especially I'm
going to use as an example well in all
my classes because they're all virtually
about the Holocaust this past semester
had the wonderful experience of
co-teaching a class at the law school on
as a result of my work on the Eichmann
trial on the impact of post-war not the
post-world War two war crimes trials
Nuremberg Eichmann and Ashford's
Frankfurt trials in Germany in 63 on
current Genocide law we had graduate
students and law students in it and it
was terribly exciting and yet we once
again figured out that you can't use the
past as a simple template for the future
but in all my classes including
certainly that class but even in my
undergraduate classes my Freshman
Seminar I'll teach a Freshman Seminar in
the fall on films of the Holocaust we
use various propaganda films feature
films compare feature films from the
sixties to feature films from the year
2000 etc etc look at the propaganda Nazi
propaganda films
American propaganda films many of the
students come in expecting me to emote
that this is you know if they're saying
that's something that they know is
horrible and that's going to be I'm
gonna tell them that it's horrible and I
don't do that I don't do that because
they need to be told that what they're
studying is horrible that you can be in
the class I mean it should be obvious
and my job is to excuse me unpack the
facts to unpack what happens and trying
to figure out how it happens and what
we're studying there is a moment when
the world we came from the world we
inhabit went terribly wrong and what I'm
trying to unpack is how did it go
terribly wrong Hitler didn't come into
power on January 30th 1933 and announced
I plan to murder a six million Jews I
plan to kill lots of handicapped Peter
man handicapped people
I plan to persecute German gays I plan
to kill lots of my military opponents
and civilian opponents he didn't make
these announcements it unfolded it
happened so what I'm trying to do with
my students is study that unfolding
study that piece by piece how does it
happen
what sort of systems break down when is
it possible still for people to protest
when is it impossible for people to
protest what's the reaction of the
person in the street
what kind of how do they acquiesce is
the German not every German you look at
Leni Riefenstahl famous documentary
triumph of the will and you see these
these German faces full of adulation for
the Fuhrer for Hitler but not everyone
was like that but there were enough
people like that
together with people who are willing to
say well I don't like all this
anti-semitism talk I don't like this
terrible expansionist talk but I've got
a good job
I don't like oh you know that what we've
made what we've done in Poland but I've
got more food than anybody else in in
all of Europe so you made accommodations
now I don't have to stand there and say
that's a bad thing to do that's for them
to figure out and that's for them to
figure out what they might do in that in
that place but at the same time I try to
be very careful
no students are self-assured as as we
get older we think history matters also
as we get older we realize we don't know
everything but my students I think come
into the class sure that they know a
whole lot more than I hope they think
that I think they'll know in 20 years
but they are convinced that they would
have done the right thing they are
convinced that they would have reacted
in a certain way and I want to
complicated for them and with that I
deal less with the perpetrators but more
with the victims for instance I have
Jewish students non-jewish students as
students of the run the gamut in the
classroom I used to be able to tell by
the names but now you can't tell by the
name O'Connor could be an Orthodox Jew
and Rosen black the vehicle alien
self-identify they mentioned they come
and they say I've studied this before
I've never studied this with my they
used to come when I first started
teaching and say might my mother is a
survivor my father survivor now they
said my grandparents survivors last year
in fact in my Freshman Seminar we were
studying about the Kindertransport the
children's taken out of Germany and
brought to England and one of the
students grandfather had been on the
Kindertransport so we went over to II
stood in the library and we Skyped the
grandpa mean who Chris he knew we didn't
just you know say hello we're here but
his his daughter went the students
mother was there to help and they
brought along 11 year old to make sure
they could get the Skype working well
and the students he could see us and we
could see him and they had this
wonderful conversation about that being
on the Kindertransport but the students
are convinced they're convinced
particularly when it comes to the
victims and to fighting back I would
have fought back I would never and
they're smart enough not to say not to
speak contemptuously of the victims but
they're but there's this sense of I
wouldn't have let this happen to me I
would have somehow escaped that wouldn't
be surprised if you get similar things
when you study about slavery I would
have escaped I would have gone I found
the Underground Railroad I would have
gotten out of there for both of you
accounts
so I say to them say I'm gonna ask you a
question to set up a scenario and end
with a question I don't want you to tell
me the answer and in truth you shouldn't
even answer it for yourself because you
really can't figure it out I said
imagine that you were in a ghetto with
your family exactly the age you are now
parents in their 40s which then of
course is ancient Oh for those days and
younger sister and brother and you have
a chance to try to escape but you know
that if you escape your family is going
to be immediately deported and you know
what deportation means no what do you do
don't answer in other words I want to
complicate it for them and the reason I
asked the suzhen to pass me over the
book is that when I was writing my book
about the iPhone truck was reading the
transcripts of the trial over and over
again I came across a very powerful
moment in the trial and I want to read
you the section they have page from it
about that but to set it up the witness
was a magistrate from Tel Aviv a man
named Moshe by szyskii who was a
survivor a Polish survivor who goes on
to occupy a very respected play a very
respected role on the High Court the
Israeli High Court the equivalent of our
Supreme Court and he's comes to the
trial to testify about his experience in
Poland and when he comes in the judges
judge Landau who just died at age 99 the
presiding judge says to him you're
welcome to sit and he says no I prefer
to stand
he's a man of the court he wants tea
fields the court deserves a certain
dignity and when you give testimony you
stand so for the first I would say half
hour 40 minutes he doesn't speak in
complete sentences he speaks in complete
paragraphs
I read the English translation I read
the original Hebrew I listened to the
transcript this guy
it just has it knows exactly what he
wants to say and how he wants to make
his point and then he begins to describe
a moment in when he's in one of the
camps when 15 thousand people 15
thousand prisoners were ordered by SS
men armed with machine guns and bayonets
to watch as a young boy was brought to
be hanged the child was lifted up to the
gallows but the rope broke by ski
recalled he was again lifted up on a
high chair which was placed
under the road the child then began to
beg for mercy
an order was given to hang him a second
time feisty had just barely begun to
describe this harrowing extreme when
prosecutor Hausner pounced 15,000 puts
people stood there and opposite of them
just a hundred a couple of hundred
guards why didn't you attack
why didn't you revolt by ski struggled
to respond the articulate witness was
replaced by a man who floundered groped
for words and left sentences unfinished
and in fact in the transcript the tread
the trench barber puts in ellipses you
know that to show that she isn't losing
words but these weren't complete
sentences this was already in the third
year of the war nonetheless there was
still hope here were people working on
forced labor maybe they needed our labor
maybe possibly then mid-sentence he
stops and turns the judge and he s
permission to sit so you can see this
man is really broken man and then he
goes on to say I cannot describe this
terror inspiring fear nearby us there
was a Polish camp there were a thousand
poles 100 metres behind the but beyond
the camp they had a place to go to their
homes
I don't recall one instance of escape on
the part of the poles but where could
any of the Jews go we were wearing
clothes which would dyed yellow with
stripes in the center of our head they
made a kind of swath in the strike four
centimeters wide and at the moment let
us suppose that the 15,000 people within
the camp even succeeded without arm
strength to go beyond the boundaries of
the camp where could they go what could
they do
you can see he's trying to portray this
so when I read and he by the way had not
yet words he confronts Hauser and says
why didn't you warn me you wouldn't ask
that Hauser said because I wanted an
answer we might say that came from the
gut I wanted an unrehearsed answer but
here's what I write in the book after
reading by skis unrehearsed answer I
photocopy copied it and flipped it
flipped the page into the fire folder I
used for my weekly lectures at Emory in
my Holocaust history course someday
probably long before this manuscript
appears as a book the student will ask
why didn't they fight back and I will
give the spontaneous
testimony Gideon Hausner elicited from a
very brave but at that moment rhe broken
man what I want to do with this material
I want them to get to think about this
moments I want them to realize how it
unfolded step by step by step but I also
want them to realize that the people to
whom it happened and the people who did
it were no different than they one hopes
basically there was a difference but
they weren't monsters they weren't
Martians who came down and somehow took
over Germany and made this happen but
these were normal people who grew up in
normal homes they weren't all bullies as
one person has tried to argue that the
Nazis world bullet the bleeding Nazis
were all bullies and that's what was
that simple too simplistic I want to
show them that history is complicated I
want to show them that it matters I've
been inundated with requests some of you
may have seen it I wrote about the dimi
on you try a trial recently Ben Laden
Milotic bin Laden look at the think of
the parallels between the Eichmann trial
and bin Laden two countries with
friendly relations with the the third
the second country Israel with Argentina
America with Pakistan go into that
country unasked unannounced to grab
someone whom they see one as a genocide
or killer of the past and other as they
see as a killer of the present in one
case he's brought to trial the other
case he's killed on the spot this is not
by any way to criticize the seals that
this was a part of armed conflict when
they went for bin Laden but but my
regret but just to talk about the
importance of trials and this morning
the BBC's that talk about melodica
arriving in The Hague and said this may
be well one of the most important post
war crimes trials the the thing that
will distinguish that trial from
Nuremberg and its results and I don't
have time really to talk about it but
maybe in the conversation the lesson we
learned from the Eichmann trial the
thing we see in the Eichmann trial is
that Gideon Hausner the prosecutor
brings close to a hundred witnesses to
tell their story in the first-person
singular
this is my story this is what
to me since the icon trial we've never
had a war crimes trial without the voice
of the victim we didn't have it at
Nuremberg that was all documents and and
that first person singular that first
person voice is so important and that's
another message I want to get across to
the students and and having said that
just I'll close by reading to you the
last paragraph of my book a number of
years ago I was invited to a conference
at Yad Vashem the memorial in the
research and Memorial Museum in
Jerusalem to the Holocaust while there I
met a group of young Rwandan who had
asked yet bashang to train them and how
to conduct oral testimony with trauma
victims they wanted to ensure that the
history of the genocide that had
decimated their country and their
families would be preserved Yad Vashem
eager to make them feel comfortable
arranged for them to have dinner on
their first night in Jerusalem with
french-speaking Holocaust survivors by
the end of the dinner the two groups of
survivors had bonded so strongly that
the elderly survivors took the young
Rwandan under their wings invited them
to their home introduce them to their
families and began to build personal
relations also wrecking the schedule of
the conference but that's for another
country
one afternoon I sat with some of the
young Rwandan Zout side of Yad Vashem
overlooking the Judean Hills they told
me of their experience during the
genocide and their meeting with the
Holocaust survivors one young man whose
entire family had been murdered said to
me quote I want to tell my story and
help my fellow Rwandan survivors tell
theirs just like the Holocaust survivors
I want people to listen to me as they
listen to them despite the inherent
contradiction in his next statement I
understood what he meant and recognized
the passion with which he said I had
heard it many times from french-speaking
from from how absurd from Holocaust
survivors future generations those who
were not there must remember and we who
were there must tell them this may be
the most enduring legacy of what
occurred in Jerusalem
1961 the telling of history the telling
of the history of history in the first
person singular we can't write history
alone from the voice of the FIR of the
the witness but the voice of the
survivor the voice of the witness has
become an integral part of our writing
of history thank you very much I just
wanted to add just a little anecdote
from my own experience and then say
something that then you all can then
enter the conversation I just got back
from taking nine students on a tour of
we called it civil rights the American
South and we started at Koinonia farms
and we went to Montgomery and then to
Lowndes County and Selma and Birmingham
and Jackson at the Delta Oxford
Mississippi and then we ended in Memphis
and after 10 days flew back home and
we're exhausted but one of the
interesting things it ties in with both
of your approaches is also how history
is remembered and there are monuments
all over the place in in the areas where
we went and it reminded us of the long
legacy of the Civil War and how much
that legacy of the Civil War you begin
to see this dual narrative between the
ways the Civil Rights history is
remembered and the way the Civil War is
remembered and so when we started in
Andersonville I wanted them to see
Andersonville and to see what had
happened and then they kept asking why
are all these northern monuments here
where in Andersonville Georgia and so we
talked some about the aftermath of the
war and who had the money to put
monuments up and why would they put them
here and and then we go into this little
village of Andersonville and there's the
monument to the the man who was the
overseer of Andersonville and there the
town got to have its say and its
monument and then through the whole trip
we kept seeing these monuments and
having these dual narratives and when we
got to Ole Miss we saw the monument to
the Confederate soldier that's right
there in the grove and is this very we
saw those kind of monuments everywhere
and then just around the corner is the
monument where james Meredith
is honored for integrating the
University of Mississippi and they sat
down and really had this long
conversation with each other about what
does it mean that this monument is here
what does this monument tell us and one
african-american student she said I just
feel like this is about the University
and not about what James Meredith had to
go through and where is the struggle and
then we talked about how do you
commemorate that how do you make a
monument to that how do we deal with
this and this if you build the Holocaust
Museum very often you'll hear from
survivors don't start with January 30th
1933 start with the world that was
destroyed tell them that we were normal
people that were regular people we had a
rich variegated life and so these
students when we got to the end there
were lots of things they learn from this
trip but they one student said I've been
in your class two classes with me the
new South and Civil Rights history and
she said I never quite understood why
you kept talking about monuments all the
time and now I can't avoid seeing them
and I really understand that but that
memory piece is another really important
part of of how we understand what
happened and it was interesting they did
not think the monument to the
Confederacy cause at Ole Miss should be
taken down they wanted it to be
contextualized they wanted it to be
explained and I love that because I felt
like they got it we don't need to remove
we need to explain so anyway so one of
the things I want to just throw out here
is that both of your approaches to
teaching history is such an invitation
you are inviting students to enter in
and to see that it's not oh I just need
to memorize these dates and memorize
these people and then that's all there
is to it and I think that invitation is
so welcoming and I just wonder do you
find that once they get over the initial
sense oh I don't have to just memorize
some dates and names that I'm really
asking to enter this story do they then
come at you in any way or can you feel
that change or how do you how do you how
do your students respond to these
invitations well different students
respond in different ways some of them
are much more enthusiastic than others
but I do think that because there's such
a lot of initial
resistance to the study of history one
of the things we've got to do as history
teachers is get over the initial sense
of resistance and particularly get back
into the feeling of contingency for me
this is the most important thing getting
people to realize that just as we don't
know what the events of the year 2015
were so nobody in 1861 knew what the
events of for 1864 were it's once it has
happened and once it's been written down
once it's been sort of consolidated
between the pages
it seems so inevitable and getting rid
of the feeling of inevitability is
really the first step so I would say
that that sense of contingency is one
thing and the other is trying to get the
students to realize that it's possible
to be enthusiastic about it
I try to put a lot of energy into it and
I sometimes say didn't I wish you had
this experience as kids you liked
history but you didn't like the dates
anyone anyone yeah nice yeah I always
always say I think the dates are
fantastic the dates are almost the best
of the lot they're so beautiful are they
we think about a date like 1915 it's so
compressed there's such an enormous
amount of information just in those four
numbers look at this photograph so a
photograph taken in 1915 look at the
1915 isness of it and and you know I saw
bobble and infuse and the kids go
whatever but here's what happens you see
it isn't this they suddenly become
enthusiastic about dates but they do
becoming but they do remember oh yeah he
was the guy who the usually has to go
bad dates it shows them that it's
possible to become enthusiastic about
all kinds of things I'm if I was
teaching statistics you know I'd be
doing the same thing about the
difference doing median and mean
probably Oh show them you can care about
this you can enjoy it just to go back to
your comment one of the things that I do
that I find well one thing I won't be
able to do much longer but first
something I use memoirs in my class even
though it's a history class we read
primo levy we look at Art Spiegelman's
Maus the comic book on just fantastic
and got the Pulitzer Prize and and
really deserved it and other but we
don't do night or Anne Frank was I
assume that they've read that but we do
memoirs and I do a whole class on
memoirs with Professor Ballmer
because I think that's such an important
entry point but I want to make another
point that both of you sort of raised
and that is you know sort of students
think they know what's coming I'll do it
Venn John said I had this conversation a
long time ago in my book on my trial
came out about the bombing of Dresden I
don't know if you remember but people
often say the bomb client came at the
end of the war it was as if the Allies
that we only have three more months to
the war it's going to end the beginning
of April in Berlin you know for the
soldier on the ground the bombing of
Dresden was much closer to what than the
end of the war the Battle of the Bulge
which was barely an allied victory
so complicate matters and then you have
this number of a hundred thousand people
killed when the city of Dresden itself
says it was 19,000 not that that's a
small number but it's a way of trying to
paint an American atrocity when it's
much more confident Rossi when it's much
more complicated and so when this end of
whenever people say things like the
movie a bridge too far you know that a
story of end of the war but you don't
know what we know it's the end of the
war but the people in the movie don't
know it's the end of the war and that's
when the things you want to sort of
impress on students to just have to
separate themselves you know from what
the South becomes to what it was then I
think both of those are very important
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University